ich begrüße ganz herzlich Johannes Vogel
den stellvertretenden Parteivorsitzenden
der FDP und auch der erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer seiner
Fraktion und Dietmar Bartsch der
Fraktionsvorsitzende Linksfraktion herr
Vogel ich habe es gerade gesagt ihr
Fraktionschef Herr dürr hat nach der
Entscheidung von Robert Habeck was die
AKWs angeht gesagt so geht das nicht wir
können nicht die Atomkraftwerke
abklemmen und der Strompreis wird immer
weiter steigen der Bundeskanzler wird
heute sicherlich auf sich auf die Seite
von Robert Habeck stellen damit es Asso
entschieden zwei Koalitionspartner sind
für diese Regelung zwei Kraftwerke in
Reserve zu halten die FDP ist massiv
dagegen hat sogar Präsidiumsbeschluss
wie geht denn das jetzt weiter ja wir
erleben doch sowieso dass wir uns daran
gewöhnen müssen dass wir
unterschiedliche Parteien haben die eine
Koalition bilden und die auch ihre
unterschiedlichen Positionen darstellen
dürfen wenn am Ende der Debatte ein
gutes Ergebnis fürs Land rauskommt und
ich finde das haben wir jetzt beim
Entlastungspaket gesehen dass ein gutes
Ergebnis rauskam dass wir gemeinsam
einen großen Wurf machen wollten und
jetzt dis wenn wir über die Frage wie
sieht es am Strommarkt aus ich kann nur
für mich sagen
es macht es hat auch für mich zum
Beispiel die Wirtschaftsweise in
Veronika Grimm letzt gestern noch mal
und die letzten Tage noch mal sehr
deutlich gemacht es macht in dieser Lage
wo wir ein Problem haben mit Versorgung
je nach Szenario und wo wir auch ein
Problem haben mit viel zu hohen
Strompreisen macht es keinen Sinn
sichere und klimaneutrale Kraftwerke vom
Netz zu nehmen und deshalb werden wir
das noch ausdiskutieren müssen aber wenn
zwei Koalitionspartner sagen das macht
Sinn auch aus ideologischen Gründen bei
den Grünen sicherlich dann kann doch die
FDP nichts mehr ausrichten oder wird es
noch ein Koalitionsausschuss geben
werden sie noch versuchen diesen
Beschluss zu kippen oder ist das jetzt
Fakt naja es folgt ja in jedem Fall aus
dem Vorschlag des bundeswirtschafts- und
Energieminister die Veränderung die
Notwendigkeit Gesetze zu verändern muss
ans Atomgesetz ran oder über ein anderes
Gesetz ans Atomgesetz ran das heißt wir
werden hier diskutieren müssen man
braucht eine Mehrheit und uns geht es um
die Sache es geht doch hier nicht um
also mir geht's nicht um Ideologie oder
um irgendwelche profilierungsfragen
sondern wir sind in einer schweren
Energiekrise ganz offensichtlich haben
wir nicht nur ein Gas sondern auch ein
Stromproblem und dann muss müssen wir
doch darüber sprechen was können wir
dagegen tun und in meinen Augen sind sie
Kapazität von drei Kernkraftwerken auf
jeden Fall etwas die ich mir nicht
dauerhaft Wünsche aber die wir jetzt in
dieser schwierigen Zeit in den nächsten
Monaten noch weiter betreiben müssen
alles andere ist doch einfach nicht
vernünftig weil das Auswirkung hat
natürlich auch Versorgungssicherheit
aber ja auch mit dem Einfluss dann auf
die Gaskraftwerke die dann den Preis am
Strommarkt setzen auf das
durchschnittliche Preisniveau und da
haben wir offensichtlich ein Problem und
wenn es offensichtlich mit Blick auf die
Vernunft Gesprächsbedarf gibt dann
müssen wir auch weiter darüber reden
aber hat sie lachen so nette die Linke
ist ja auch für das Auslaufen der AKWs
die Lösung die der Herr Bartsch jetzt
verlangen Herr Habeck da präsentiert
Herr Bartsch ist die denn sinnvoll denn
es wurde mal ausgerechnet das wird
mindestens 45 Millionen kosten die am
Netz zu halten aber sie werden keinen
Strom liefern ist das ein sinnvolles
Verfahren
schauen Sie die stimme zu dass wir einen
Strom und ein Energieproblem und ein
gasproblem haben sowohl was die
Versorgung als auch was den Preis
betrifft ich finde das hier eine
Regelung gefunden worden ist die vor
allen Dingen dafür sorgen soll dass die
grüne Basis die Entscheidung des
Novembers dass man nämlich weiter am
Netz bleibt schlucken kann das ist doch
der Kern es geht um den Frieden in der
Ampel und es geht überhaupt nicht darum
wie rational entschieden werden kann da
kann man unterschiedliche Sichten haben
ich kenne die der FDP für weiterbetriebe
das ist zulässig aber was jetzt gemacht
wird ist um den Frieden in der Ampel wie
beim Entlastungspaket es wird für jeden
etwas gemacht und völlig aus dem Blick
geraten die Menschen die in riesen
Sorgen sind das ist das was ich auch der
Ampel beim Entlastungspaket vorwerfe es
wird riesig aufgebläht also verbal und
wenn man mal real hinschaut dann ist es
vielfach völlig unzureichend ich will
nur das Thema Kindergeld erwähnen 18
Euro weil wir haben acht Prozent
Inflation noch das wären zehn Prozent
und dann gibt es 18 Euro am 1 Januar die
Inflation ist jetzt das ist für all
diejenigen um nur diesen einen Punkt zu
nennen völlig unzureichen und bei den
Atomkraftwerken ist das Friede der Ampel
und nicht etwa ein Sachproblem da kann
man dann entscheiden das hätte man tun
können Auslaufen Punkt oder wegen meiner
auch Verlängerung was ich nicht teile
aber diese Art und Weise der Grünen
Basis eine Brücke zu bauen dass man dann
im November wegen der schwierigen Lage
müssen sie weiterlaufen das geht so
nicht in der Ampel ist ja die Frage die
FDP sehr unzufrieden und sie könnte noch
unzufriedener werden herr Vogel denn
Herr bartschatz gerade angesprochen dass
Kindergeld da gab es auch massiv Kritik
von Friedrich Merz und der Union das
wird jetzt nachgebessert da wird für das
dritte Kind jetzt auch draufgelegt dann
ist heute morgen von Frau Mast zu hören
der parlamentarischen Geschäftsführerin
der SPD das wahrscheinlich noch ein
weiteres Paket folgen muss auch ihr
Parteivorsitzender und Finanzminister
hat in einem großen Interview gesagt
also wir versuchen alles aber wenn es
nicht anders geht dann müssen wir noch
mal nachlegen das würde ja auch bedeuten
wahrscheinlich dass die Schuldenbremse
nicht zu halten und der Mittelstand hat
sich heute auch massiv beschwert hat
gesagt wir sind in dieser
Regierungskoalition gar nicht mehr
vertreten unsere Interessen werden da
nicht wahrgenommen der hat auch Robert
Habeck gestern abend noch mal erklärt
wir werden für die auch noch was tun da
kommt riesig viel auf sie zu
wahrscheinlich wird die Schuldenbremse
nicht zu halten seine Vogel nein wir
sind doch in einer doppelten Krise wir
sind in der Energiekrise und wir haben
eine Inflation die immer heftiger wird
und ja auch sich von den Energiepreisen
in die sogenannte Kerninflation
reinfrisst und wenn sie dann darüber
reden und mit klugen
Wirtschaftswissenschaft entsprechen was
ist in Zeiten der Inflation zu tun dann
ist es nicht schuldenfinanzierte
Ausgabenprogramme zu machen weil das
belastet die Menschen und das frisst den
Menschen eben auch das Einkommen weg und
deshalb ist diese Situation so
herausfordernd und ich glaube genau
gerade deshalb ist es auch fatal wenn
wir jetzt so mit den klassischen
Kategorien darüber reden gibt es kleine
positionsunterschiede der Parteien geht
es um Frieden oder um Streit darum geht
es nicht sondern wir sind einer
absoluten Ausnahmesituation wir dürfen
übrigens auch kurz noch mal festhalten
wo die herkommt dass wir so schlecht
vorbereitet in dieser Situation zum
Beispiel Energiepolitik als Land sind
das sind langfristige energiepolitische
Fehlentscheidung der letzten Jahre
daraus müssen was lernen für die Lehren
für die Zukunft langfristig zu denken
aber die Ursache von all dem ist eine
einzige allein ich Wladimir Putin und
das was er sich wünscht das wäre jetzt
in interne Konflikte als Gesellschaft
uns begeben das sollten wir den gefallen
sollten wir ihnen nicht tun und ich
glaube dass das Entlastungspaket eines
ist was bei der Entlastung steuerlichen
Entlastung der breiten Mitte war es bei
der gezielten weiteren Unterstützung
gerade von kleinen Einkommen eine ganz
ganze Menge schafft die Frage der
Energiepreise die ist eine die wir
ergänzend leisten müssen und deswegen
ist es Entlastungspaket ja nicht nur
eins was finanziell entlastet sondern
gehen wir auch an strommarktdesign ran
weil wir eine Ausnahmesituation sind das
fällt niemandem leicht aber das ist
notwendig und deswegen müssen wir auch
an die Frage ran wie viel wo kommt denn
die Energie her wo kommt denn das
Angebot her und darüber haben wir gerade
gesprochen und dann Blick auf die Sache
da sehe ich anders als die Opposition
das legitim dass die Opposition
kritische Fragen stellt ist auch legitim
dass die Linkspartei immer sagt es
könnte noch mehr sein dass ihre
klassische Rolle aber wir müssen agieren
am Ende mit einer vernünftigen Lösung
das gebietet die Lage in dem Fall hat
das mehr Geld gar nicht die Opposition
zwar gefordert aber mittlerweile ja
schon Regierungsvertreter zugesagt wie
Robert Habeck das für den Mittelstand
noch was passiert
Wirtschaftshilfen muss was passieren es
muss was passieren bei den
Energiepreisen das ja auch klar
verabredet das ist jetzt erst der Blick
nach Europa weil die EU-Kommission etwas
angekündigt hat und wenn die nicht ganz
kurzfristig agiert dann agieren wir und
generell bleiben wir handlungsfähig in
schwieriger Lage jederzeit diese
reagieren 65 Milliarden ist eine Menge
sie haben das Scheinriese genannt und
zwar weil eigentlich das Geld ja
sozusagen die Koalition durch die
Situation eigentlich einnimmt nur einmal
das wenn man sich nur die Einnahmen aus
der Mehrwertsteuer anschaut wenn das bis
zum Jahresende 50 bis 60 Milliarden sein
und 65 Milliarden ist sehr sehr viel
Geld gar keine Frage Rassismus mal
erwähnen dass ein relevanten Teil die
Länder tragen werden und dann will ich
mal einmal dagegen stellen das in einer
nachtentscheidung der Bundeskanzler
mitgeteilt hat 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen was auch nichts anderes
als Schulden sind aber damit man die
Schuldenbremse einhält wird das so
gemacht will ich nicht noch mal darlegen
das ging über Nacht und hier werden 65
Milliarden als ein Riesenpaket verkauft
wenn man sich anschaut was schon vorher
klar war da alles mit reingerechnet
worden und es gibt so große weiße
Flecken mein mich wundert dass ein
Vertreter der FDP gerade bei den
Wirtschaftshilfen nicht sagt ja
selbstverständlich ist hier viel zu
wenig getan und selbstverständlich
brauchen wir ein weiteres
Entlastungspaket das hört sich auch mal
so an wir entlassen erstmals belastet
worden das wird das Problem derzeit man
muss sich dann nur angucken wie viel
Insolvenzen es gibt wie viel
Arbeitsplätze das kostet ich höre nur
Horrornachrichten gerade auch aus den
neuen Ländern und da muss man etwas tun
da kann man nicht sagen ach eigentlich
sind wir schon ganz schön toll und die
Koalition hält zusammen nein es stimmt
ja völlig richtig wir haben eine
multiple-krise und der Putins Krieg
dieser furchtbare Angriffskrieg
Russlands hat das alles verschärft aber
wer dann sagt es der alleinige Grund ist
einfach nicht wahr die Energiekrise die
Inflation war vorher bereits hoch wir
hatten vorher bereits ein
Versorgungsproblem die ganze Frage Klima
die spielt jetzt keine Rolle mehr das
geht deswegen ja an Herrn Vogel sondern
eher an die Grünen das 1,5 Grad Ziel der
das können wir irgendwie in den Wind
schreiben also diese vielen Krisen da
erwarte ich dass wir in einer
gemeinsamen Kraftanstrengung natürlich
die Regierung aber bitte auch unter
Aufnahme der Hinweise der Opposition
agieren weil wir haben sonst eine
Situation dass wir ein wirklich heißen
Herbst bekommen der soziale Friede in
unserem Land ist gefährdet man muss sich
mit den Menschen unterhalten die
wirklich am Monatsende schon lange kein
Geld mehr haben und da muss gehandelt
werden dass es meine feste Überzeugung
wir zumindest werden weiter Druck machen
dass ein viertes Entlastungspaket wie
immer man das nennt denn diese Haushalt
der hier behandelt wird ist letztlich
Makulatur es muss alles neu gemacht
werden dass das aber wirklich die
Verluste ausgleicht das muss dringend
notwendig sein
Kroatien dieser Sekunde Frau Mast hat
das heute morgen auch unterfüttert ist
wird neue Pakete geben müssen
schätzungsweise den allein die
Arbeitslosigkeit über die hat noch
überhaupt keiner gesprochen die letzten
Wochen und Monate die wird jetzt
galoppieren zunehmen alleine da wird der
Bundesfinanzminister schon nach Nürnberg
viel mehr Geld überweisen müssen sie
werden doch daran nicht vorbeikommen wir
wissen doch die doppelte Krise
verantwortungsbewusst bewältigen und das
heißt wir haben eine Krise bei Energie
wir haben eine Notwendigkeit gezielt zu
entlasten und wir haben eine Krise bei
Inflation das belastet die Bürger
mittelfristig auch am schärfsten wenn
sich das rein frisst so und da müssen
wir Verantwortung bewusst agieren das
geht wenn wir uns die Lage anschauen und
Opposition und Regierung vielleicht
gemeinsam verantwortungsvoll agieren
dann wäre das gut das geht aber ganz
sicher nicht dadurch dass die Opposition
in den klassischen Modus verfällt immer
zu sagen höher schneller weiter und vor
allem Dinge gegeneinander ausspielt also
100 Milliarden Entlastungen sind jetzt
dieses Jahr auf dem Weg und natürlich
mussten wir 100 Milliarden in die Hand
nehmen und die Bundeswehr handlungsfähig
zu machen weil wir hatten Krieg in
Europa haben und dann mir Putin nicht in
Ukraine zwingend Halt macht wenn man ihm
nicht Einhalt gebietet so also das
gegeneinander ausspielen so in die
klassischen Reflexe verfallen das
überzeugt mich nicht zielgenau zu
entlasten und auch breit und mit einem
kräftigen Paket zu entlasten ist ja
genau was wir seit Wochen im Sommer
diskutiert haben was wir jetzt tun und
jetzt muss er gucken welche Elemente
fehlen noch aber das Gegeneinander wenn
ich das sagen darf das wird deshalb
schon nicht funktionieren weil nur für
die Nachfolgeregelung des neuen
euro-tickets wie immer sie dann aussehen
mag sehr offen wenn Sie die Zustimmung
im Bundesrat brauchen das ist nur ein
Punkt
entweder entweder sie kriegen das so hin
dass sie das auch mit den
Oppositionsparteien machen die auch
Regierungsverantwortung tragen wie in
vier Ländern die Union in viel mehr oder
es wird nichts deswegen kann ich nur
raten hier nicht zu sagen auch die Ampel
ist schon klasse und nur ihr seid die
ewigen nörgel und wollt mehr nein es
geht um qualitative Dinge sie haben vom
Strompreis
aber dann bauen sie doch keine
Strohmänner auf sie haben jetzt das
dritte mal gesagt was ich angeblich
gesagt habe was ich vorher gar nicht
gesagt habe lassen wir doch das
ritualisierte und Anerkennung welcher
Ausnahme Lage
die Leute haben Angst die Leute merken
auch dass es knapp werden wird die
Politiker sagen es Ihnen ja auch das
wird ein ganz schwieriger Herbst werden
und da geht die Linke nun hin und ruft
die Menschen auf auf die Straße zu gehen
mit dem Motto heißer Herbst gegen
soziale Kälte und was eigentlich für sie
noch schlimmer wiegen mag ist dass sie
sich im Grunde genommen da an die Seite
der rechten begeben die nämlich
teilweise mit ihnen auf dem gleichen
Platz am Wochenende demonstriert haben
und die AFD hatte fast den gleichen
Slogan heißer Herbst statt kalte Füße
kommen sie da nicht eine ganz komische
Ecke also erstens demonstrieren wir
nicht mit rechten gemeinsam wir haben
doch kein Abgrenzungsproblem das
versuchen diejenigen die diesen Protest
denunzieren wollen und ich sage ganz
klar wir brauchen beides die
Auseinandersetzung in den Parlamenten
aber bitte auch den Protest auf der
Straße weil nur der wird dazu führen und
das haben wir gesehen wieso gibt es denn
300 Euro jetzt auch für Rentnerinnen und
Rentner wieso gibt's das für Studierende
ich habe vor Monaten noch gehört wie
alle schlau erklärt haben wie richtig
das ist jetzt auf einmal ist diese
Entscheidung richtig sehr gut aber ich
kann nur sagen der Druck der Straße war
entscheidend wie beim 9 € Ticket beides
ist notwendig damit sich die Regierung
bewegt und wir haben keinen
Abgrenzungsproblem rechts hat mit uns
nicht zu tun Punkt meine Herren vielen